um like decisions based on how they feel
yeah at that time
is just hilarious
designed by God I just hope is it
working for you guys I just hope it's
working if he's working I do I do agree
earlier what you said about the it's
about how you make someone feel I don't
think it's relevant to them exactly to
the money it looks however how you make
them it's all about how to make it how
they make you feel and the experience
that you bring them and what triggers in
their minds I'll give you an example so
my block list is full of people yeah men
women whoever yeah but if I was to
unblock someone and start talking to
them again they're instantly going to
romanticize any experience that we've
had and that's that's more important so
if you've made them feel even if you've
made them feel shitty yeah that will
work but it's similarly like why women
that didn't grow up with money if they
meet a really rich guy he's most
attractive man in the room because she
feels now financially secure she hasn't
felt for in a long time most women that
marry for money come from broken homes
less attractive are more likely to be
invested in a man who's attracted looks
is more important so it's about how you
make someone feel rather than just
generic interesting women are more picky
physically than men nowadays
there's different studies that say like
women are pickier when it comes to look
similar yeah
is that weird not really but it is when
you're you're not actually going towards
the guys so you know you're just showing
in your gene pool
but that's why I'm you know body
positivity is not for men it's just for
women yeah in fact fat guys are still
fat guys short guys are still short guys
no one cares about that okay body
positivity is if there is a short man
shaming I'm sure
like five was it five seven energy or
whatever
I actually think is it is being a short
man the equivalent of being an
overweight woman what classifies as a
short man as well um
short men are allowed to be angry and
overweight women kind of aren't allowed
to be angry so they are though what are
you talking about they're wrong
everyone's angry it's like oh it's weird
it's worse than a short man being angry
you see a short angry man every day
okay
you can at least like do something to be
able to change it but when you're short
as a guy yeah anyway that's true short
people syndrome as well because they
just go mad for no reason yeah I think I
think that no yeah
I've been attacked by Fats yeah
the first-hand experience I've never
been attacked by a short man but the fat
chicks come for you why
okay it's like a trigger basically so
yeah with all this body positivity is
going on but you know what's worse about
this and what's the frustration that
comes from it like that's something that
can be done but women will like ridicule
guys for their height and then there's
nothing they can do now you can get you
can get you can get um
I'll give you two sentences right what
do you think would have more of a public
uproar so I say I don't date short guys
men don't like fat chicks second one
yeah of course
from who the media I feel like the media
is controlled by no no feminine energy
by both groups yeah like I say I don't
date short guys and I never really have
a reaction so I don't like it sure but
if I say men don't ditch fat chicks
typically I have this in my time I said
I have never dated a girl over Thai 12.
it got picked up by UK gossip and
everyone slated me for it do you guys
ever date fat chicks
size 12 no I know some girls in size
toes God damn they're volunteers good
juicy I wouldn't call that fat yeah you
got fat on you but that's not fat to me
yeah so like it kind of depends you
could be fat and shaped I love chili fat
what no shape no shape you're not
attractive like that's that's something
that needs to be worked on yeah I think
that it's okay to accept that being over
even when I put on weight I accept that
I'm not attractive In This Moment Like
if I put on weight and so I don't think
how much weight you're pulling away you
don't think you try to do
um I've never been that big the most
I've ever been is probably 65 kg I think
yeah
but for me that's that and then I do
just accept I'm less attractive I don't
think I don't get offended but how how
do you like are there any indicators
like within like the guys that approach
you depending on what your weight is yes
you know it is we're going to talk about
it but yeah I know I've lost weight when
I appeal to a certain demographic and I
know I've gained weight when I appeal to
a different demographic and make up that
what you will which is yeah
okay okay okay so following Tom and Tom
and Giselle
how long is too long to move on or do
you think that after a divorce there's a
certain amount of time you should wait
to move on yeah yeah
[Music]
okay so how how long is that I'd say
foreign
maybe a year I know if you want to see
someone before then just don't be super
bait about it I think women tend to move
on quicker than men anyway but
um yeah I'd say about a year if you're
doing something there just try and keep
it under wraps a little bit I'll say
five to seven working days
do you know you know what it is yeah
like women this is what I kind of read
about women women will go through this
emotional transition straight away and
kind of get over it and you know they'll
have their girls kind of gassing them up
away along the way where guys will kind
of Brave it out I didn't be like six
months down the line and just he just
gets a shot in his chest when he just
remembers like he lost you and it's like
one of those things it kind of hits men
a bit later on yeah but I think um yeah
just get out there man because if you're
gonna spend time thinking about that
person and you know that time is gone
I would say yeah especially if you've
got kids I don't think you should bring
I think when you start distracting
yourself with men when you've got kids
your priority no longer becomes your
kids so I think the priority of post
divorce should be their well-being and
that should take a year for both of them
they need to adapt and adjust so if
you're out there meeting new men
immediately your kids are suffering and
I don't think that's a good look yeah
actually what's the marriage situation
because she's right because it's
different if you've got kids and if you
don't have kids for with kids
what about you guys um yeah I would say
year as well I mean you should give
yourself a break as well to understand
what's going on and you shouldn't just
like like complete the void of the
previous man with another one or the
woman if that makes sense so give
yourself a break to understand because
he said emotional you know you go
through some emotional Transitions and
all that so you need to give yourself a
break to understand what's going on what
about you I think yes you were like go
go right away because one I feel like if
it's a divorce then it's probably been
like a long time coming so you know I
don't know you probably are in a mental
space where you're already ready to step
out of the relationship but then with
having kids it makes it a bit more
sticky because like yeah you can't
really be bringing random people around
with your kids but you know
you don't have to necessarily even bring
them home or anything I would say as
soon as you feel like it
feel think about how it broke down and
try and fix that about yourself like
what you paid apart in that yeah and
then when you kind of feel like you're
making Headway with it then get into a
relationship but I feel like all you are
capping with the moving on in terms of
like physically but I think emotionally
like maybe yeah and maybe I should give
it a bit of time after you've actually
figured out what happened in your last
one do you guys think that women
mentally leave before they break up a
relationship yes I have to say this I
don't want to have guaranteed sex with
you anymore as many of you know I was
just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible